la fermeture de l'usiné c'est devenu de
plus en plus difficile les gens avaient
de moins en moins de pognon dans le coin
on était prêt à prendre tout ce qui se
présente est foutu ma femme pourquoi moi
parce que je t'aime bien celle des potes
de prendre la sauce une plus flatté
après deux ans de chômage
c'est rassurant de savoir qu'on voit
encore quelque chose pour quelqu'un
c'est bon elle est là tu ta femme pour
les pâtes
il m'est souvent arrivé d'avoir envie de
devenir un mari un père nature jamais
j'ai toujours été honnête jusqu'au bout
des ongles
j'ai dit que nature et donc la durée
jacques aucune trace respect total dont
thomas serais tu pas envie de devenir
tueur à gages qu'a2a comment ce que
vient de faire un moment d'égarement
je dois manquer de vocabulaire victoria
- il veut toujours devoir rester un peu
plus longtemps que prévu
parce que ce qui se passe ici ne me
plaît pas du tout et vous voulez quoi
les filles j'ai pris ça va c'est ça qui
tracasse
on dit toujours 50 50 70 30 pas
négociable pour ma femme tu m'as près -
c'est la femme d'un ami pour la première
fois depuis neuf mois
je me sens fort jax coran est de retour
la fringue et ma femme mon chien ton
patron tu qu'un vrai danger public
la malade toi tu as tu m'a dit attention
moi j'ai cru qu'il avait un flingue
dégage tu vois la mesa bousille 1 alors
arrête